today we're talking taxes and we're
talking taxes because taxes are my
favorite subject they became my favorite
subject when I paid way too much in tax
when I sold my company and I was so
happy and so sad at the same time
today's guest had the same problem he
sold teachable for over $200 million and
then decided you know what he's goingon
to go on a renegade to make sure that no
entrepreneur pays more taxes than they
need to um we basically invited him here
and he was like you know I could talk
about my story I could talk about my
life we were like no dude talk about
[Music]
taxes Anor welcome to the show man uh
and it's a long time coming yeah I'm
excited to be here it's weird how I've
now accumulated a lot of specific
knowledge in this one kind of very
narrow topic and I'm excited to share it
and the summary of your story and we'll
talk about a little bit later in the
episode but we want to talk about tax
summary of story is Prodigy entrepreneur
had a bunch of stuff started in college
you started a company called teachable
sold it for $250 million and you were 31
uh that was like a courses business now
you've got a new thing was called carry
now oh no was called oo now called
carrye and it's like a 401k like a
self-directed 401k thing yeah absolutely
it's basically the bigger vision is how
do we help people build wealth by saving
money on taxes and the solo 401K is our
first product but yeah that's the story
The quick sort of other bit is I did not
grow up in America so I knew nothing
about the US Financial system the
country I grew up in never had taxes
taxes were just not a thing that existed
in Oman where I grew up so the first
time I heard about taxes was when I was
21 years old I was like wow you actually
have to give money that you earn this is
crazy uh but yeah you got most of the
story by the way before we talk taxes I
know we're supposed to start with the
taxes thing yeah you you you have earned
your seat on my first million you made
your first million bucks when you were
like 20 years old right with something
pretty funny well can you tell that
story can you tell the fast version of
that story yeah absolutely I was in I
was in college at Berkeley and at the
time Facebook released the Facebook
platforms you could you know send gifts
to people answer quizzes and all of that
and I built these viral Facebook
applications starting from when I was 18
all the way to 20 and it was really fun
I mean you know we created personality
quizzes like you could answer a few
questions and find out how good a kisser
you are or which friend's character
you're most like if if you have to take
a Facebook quiz to figure out if you're
a good kisser you're probably a bad
kisser right well the funny thing is I'm
not I'm not going to name names one of
the Facebook Founders actually took that
quiz multiple times and I know that
because you get their Facebook user ID
in the database so user ID number I'm
not going to tell you which number it is
is was in our database and we're like
wow this person really wanted to know
but anyways yeah so we created these
personality quizzes and then friend
quizzes and stuff and yeah you know
millions of daily users uh was able to
make a million dollars before S21 which
was pretty cool yeah that's amazing um
so you you've earned your your street
credit here for us uh on my first
million all right so let's talk let's
talk taxes if I'm an entrepreneur what
are the biggest things I need to know
about taxes what are the things I should
be knowledgeable of and do doing in
order to save money cool the first thing
I think everyone should know even people
who are not entrepreneurs yet is the US
tax code is rigged in favor of business
owners um it's very intentional but you
can look at a country's tax code and
learn a lot about what it stands for and
in America two things stand out the tax
code is rigged in favor of people
involved in real estate it's the most
tax advantag asset class and two people
who start businesses so the first thing
I tell someone is if you are a full-time
W2 employee somewhere if you are not yet
a business owner consider becoming a
business owner since it is the single
biggest thing you can do to optimize
your taxes like that is just written
into the DNA of this country and it's
something that I never realized until I
started digging and was like wow there's
the playbook for what you can do to pay
less in taxes is 10 times bigger if you
are a business owner so it's rigged in
favor of business owners and real estate
and most people kind of ignore this I
would say like the advice I got growing
up was you know go to a good school so
you can get a good job that's what
winning was
and um and even the advice around money
which was kind of like you know hope you
try try to get like a raise maybe 10%
you know try to save but the hard part
about saving is that your biggest
expense is taxes right your your your
taxes might be 30 to 50% depending on
where you live and and how what bracket
you're in uh that's your biggest expense
and that's every single year off every
dollar you make unless you're able to
Shield it with some of these uh these
things you're G talk about I think I I
don't know if you remember but Warren
Buffett back in the day had a famous
quote where he's like my secretary pays
a higher tax rate than than than I do
right yeah what an
well I think I think the issue
though it's not an issue just it is what
it is if you have W2 income I'm almost
positive there's close to no way that
you can reduce that your tax liability
other than maybe um like minor
percentage
points you can do crazy stuff by using
your spouse you can have your spouse
become a real estate professional so
then you as a couple can write write off
real estate depreciation but you have to
get pretty fancy to do things with W2 so
you're right there is a universe of
things just much smaller and then like
let's say I make a million dollars a
year as a business owner like I I
actually don't know what the savings can
be I know with qsbs I saved a huge sum
but I don't know what I could reduce my
my taxable income by as a business owner
but I know it's a lot whereas the W2 it
ain't well let's tell the W2 story real
quick because uh I know people in San
Francisco that have high paying jobs at
like you know a Facebook or Google and
you know they're marrying somebody and
they're like hey guess what honey you're
a real estate broker now they're like
what I don't want to do real estate you
want you're a real estate professional
now it's like they have to get get the
status and then they're buying airbnbs
in order to offset their uh their W W2
income we literally say that like tongue
and cheek right we have a presentation
on like how do you lower your tax bill
as a W2 professional Point number three
is marry a real estate professional like
it's like tongue and cheek but it
actually it actually one of the very few
things you can do as a W2 professional
but I don't think anyone pays more in
taxes than highly paid Tech employees
like in terms of tax bracket that's
about as bad as you can get you know two
people in San Francisco making $400,000
a year together cool you're paying half
of it in taxes yeah and is before it
even comes to you it's just taken out of
your paycheck before you even get it um
all right so let's say we are an
entrepreneur Sam mentioned qsbs I'm
guessing that's going to be number one
on your list because it's such a huge
Advantage explain what it is and then
explain the kind of beginner level and
then the advanced level version of doing
it cool so four big letters in the US
tax code this may be the single most
generous tax break available today it's
called qsbs qualified small business
stock this is insane so when you look at
all these tech companies being built and
sold the reality is most of them are
going to have shareholders that pay very
little in taxes and that's because of
what's called qsbs which roughly says if
you hold shares in a C corporation for
five years you pay no taxes on up to $10
million in gains um it applies to
Founders it applies to employees it also
applies to investors and it's such a
generous tax you're forgetting the up to
10 million or 10 times your basis
whichever is greater great point it's a
great point it's either $10 million or
10 times what you pay for the shares as
a Founder it's most likely going to be
10 million since you buy your shares for
almost nothing but this is this is
massive like when I sold my company I
live in New York state and in New York
state even New York State doesn't charge
you taxes so I only had to pay New York
City taxes on the first $10 million in
gains and this is just by size of
benefit it's absurd right because you
think about W2 employees getting taxed
so heavily and here you have startup
Founders employees investors paying
nothing on10 million when they sell
their company Sean I think California is
the only state that doesn't recognize
qsbs there's actually six there's
actually six or seven states there's a
couple that partially don't recognize it
43 don't 43 um you'd pay no state taxes
as well
all right everyone a quick break to tell
you about HubSpot and this one's really
easy for me to talk about because I'm
going to show you a real life example so
I've got this company called Hampton
join hampton.com it's a community for
Founders doing between 2 million all the
way up to like $250 million a year in
revenue and one of the ways that we've
grown is we've created these cool
surveys and so we have a lot of Founders
who have high net worths and we'll ask
them all types of questions that people
typically are embarrassed to ask but
provide a lot of value so things like
how much the founders pay themselves
each month how much money they're
spending each month what their payroll
looks like if they're optimistic about
the next year and their business all
these questions that people are afraid
to ask but well we ask them anyway and
they tell us in this Anonymous survey
and so what we do is we created a
landing page using HubSpot landing page
tool and it basically has a landing page
that says here's all the questions we
asked give us your email if you want to
access it and then I shared this page on
Twitter and we were able to get
thousands of people who gave us their
email and told us they want this survey
and I could see did they come from
social media I can see did they come
from Twitter from LinkedIn basically
everywhere else that they could possibly
come from I'm able to track all of that
and then then I'm able to see over the
next handful of weeks how many of those
people actually signed up and became a
member of Hampton in other words I can
see how much revenue came from this
survey how much revenue came from each
traffic Source things like that but the
best part is I can see how much revenue
came from it and a lot of times it takes
a ton of work to make that happen
HubSpot made that super super easy if
you're interested in doing this you can
check it out hubspot.com the Link's in
the description and I also put the link
to the survey that I did so you can
actually see the landing page and how it
worked and everything like that I'm just
going to do that call to action then
and it's free check it out in the
description all right now back to MFM if
you're not paying any taxes on 10
million in gains you would normally
otherwise pay long-term capital gains
which would be roughly 20% plus there's
like a 3.6% something extra fee so it's
like you know basically 2.3 million is
what you get net extra correct that's
that's the actual in your pocket in New
York substantially more don't forget
there's another million plus in New York
taxes that I'm not paying Okay cool so
and then yeah so for California you'll
pay pay another 133% on top if New York
if you're in one of the QBs uh you know
free states then you're saving another
let's say million to Mill 1.3 million in
uh in additional state taxes so about
two and a half to three and a half
million dollars in your pocket yep or or
I've got a friend who had a company who
was uh I won't say publicly but Anker
you and I are very close friend who had
a company that was I think an sc Corp he
uh converted to a C Corp at a $30
million valuation and So eventually when
he sells it will be 10 time 30 so $300
million so that difference which is uh I
can't do the math but 20 20 $270 million
gain that will be the taxfree portion I
was I was saving that for the advanced
strategies but yeah there's a there's a
lot you can do to truly like multiply
this benefit so I heard about the 10
million thing and I was like wow this is
insane like really really cool but then
I found out that the limit is per
shareholder per company so where this
gets interesting is if I give some
shares to my mom my brother my dad each
of us now have our own $10 million limit
so as a family we have a $40 million
limit or if you go down the estate
planning rabbit hole which it's a little
complicated but at a certain point you
know hire an attorney figure it out um
you can set up trust I set up trust for
my future children trust for charity and
each of these trusts get their own $10
million benefit which multiplies this
theoretically as many times as possible
personally so what happens if you what
if you set up for three future kids and
you only have one Future kid um you can
basically set up like so what I did for
instance right I have no kids is you can
set it up for future beneficiaries as
well so it's any of my future children
are entitled to to have the trust what's
important is it's an irrevocable gift
you can't take it back yourself okay but
when if you don't have kids now um it
has to go to either my parents my
brother I've named a bunch of different
beneficiaries so there's like a line
there's like a there's like a order
order
yeah you're like the only Brown parents
who are like oh Anor it's okay if you
don't have children it's okay as long as
you're happy as long as you're happy
it's okay I wish I wish honestly that
would be it would be worth the $10
million to not be harassed by my
parents so this is called like stackable
trust right like this is called qsbs
stacking so couple of things I didn't
realize the first time around that I'm
doing differently this time around so
the first time around I was the only
person to hit the holding threshold
because I didn't realize how this works
but this time around I've given all my
early team members shares instead of
options so they can start their clock
ticking that's a really important thing
that a lot of people don't realize is
you have to own the shares for five
years not options the way that companies
get around this right is you do the 83b
election right uh and you basically buy
your shares at the super low
price we should explain how archaic the
IRS is so there's this thing called the
83b which I don't exactly know what it
means but it's basically you may
whenever I start a company I've got to
write a check to myself for $100 or I
write from s par to the name of the
company Inc and I have to mail it to the
IRS and I like handw write on it and I
write a letter to them and I say this is
s par I'm writing you one check for
$100 and I'm literally writing this out
by hand will you please uh send this
sted envelope back to me that has proof
that you receive this it's literally
like the Tooth Fairy dude yeah it's like
the tooth fairy and you write the you
write address and you just write like
IRS like uh I forget where it is in
California and by the way you have to do
this three weeks I think or 90 days 30
days 30 days 30 days 30 days after you
do this they have to get it and so right
when you file the company you've got to
run to the convenience so I get your
stamp and envelope and hurry up and do
this thing and then you write this out
and somehow this works and what's even
crazier is the IRS won't check in on you
to make sure you did this right unless
you get in trouble and you have to like
save this like envelope like gotcha
I got the envelope I filed it away
like it's crazy how this works and if
you don't do it you have to pay millions
of dollars in taxes like it's a very
very hundreds of millions yeah it's a
very high stakes document yeah it's a
high stakes document and you like have
to write it I remember like thinking
like I gotta make sure my seven is
perfectly clear so that's not a t or
like it's like a very stressful thing
and you have to write it up by hand it's
crazy how like archaic it is I I didn't
understand this rule um but our CFO was
like hey did you do your 83b and I'm
like n no it's be fine she's like no no
you have to do it within 30 days and I
was like okay well can you just like you
know where's the form can you send me
the link she's like no no you have to
print this out you got to go take it to
the post office and I was like oh man
and she looked at me she's like you
don't do those types of things do you I
was like no I don't run errands like
that I I I just simply don't I'm out of
the postal system like I don't mail
things I don't check my mail like I'm
out of that whole system in general yeah
you're like how many SS do I you like 50
40 was what part do I lick and I'm like
licking the form and I'm like then I I I
finally have it and I realized I'm on
day 37 and so for the next five years it
just haunted me I was like I didn't do
that goddamn form and then when my
company finally basically failed I was
like didn't matter I was like it didn't
come back to bite me because I was for
five years had been dreading that my
lack of uh you know belief in doing
like doing annoying paperwork things was
going to bite me and I was so happy when
that one entity failed and that the
other entity was the one that old I was
like this is this is amazing but here's
the crazier part is you can claim you
did it in time right so very technically
what the document means is it says I am
like tax me on what the value is today
I'm choosing to be taxed up front but if
not for signing this anytime your
company grows in valuation you could
theoretically be liable for taxes can
you imagine what a nightmare that is
like let's say you raise a series a a
series B A series C yeah you would not
you wouldn't have money you wouldn't
have money but you'd have a tax bill
it's like really really bad so there's a
dark side to this which is that uh
sometimes if you join a company later
like I think bolt got was pretty popular
this happened at bolt so bolt was like
hey we are lending our our employees
money to buy their shares God that was
such a Shell at a like five billion
or 10 billion dollar valuation and they
were like see this is great because now
they're goingon to start their clock of
owning the shares but people were like
okay so what happens if the valuation
goes down and there like now not only do
my shares become worthless I owe the
money for those shares at that premium
value valuation and people were like
this is not going to end well the full
story hasn't played out you know bolt is
uh is still going so it's it's unclear
exactly what's going to happen with that
it's trending in the direction like that
was a bad idea I think it's undoubtedly
a bad idea it was a 2021 valuation like
tens of billions of dollars like it's
it's not good and people saw it coming
and it's it's really bad when you now
like I'm I'm hoping they forgive those
loans because otherwise you have not
only are you making nothing in equity
you have you owe 80 $100,000 just for
working there at our company our
investor was like here's the promissary
note you don't have to come up with the
cash and we'll forgive this if this ever
happens and I was like can you write
that they're like no we can't write that
down it's like you just have to trust us
I like okay I do trust you and they did
if they if they would have write it down
it's taxed to you as income so that's
why they can write it down right yeah
all right I want to go to the counter
opinion so we got friends who you know
they're like oh the number one thing get
out of California you schmuck uh come to
come to Texas no no no forget Texas
you're still feder paying federal tax
come to Puerto Rico what do you think
about that should you should I move to
Puerto Rico to save money in taxes
according to so to me this gets to the
meta level right like why do we have
money what is the point of money and I
think there's two camps of people camp
one is like they look at their life as
as this vessel to make as much money as
possible and other people look at money
as a tool to live the life you want so I
very firmly fit into the latter camp
where money enables me to live the life
I want yes I don't want to pay more in
taxes than I have to and you know
gamifying the tax system is also fun
just because like I'm a hustler and it's
kind of fun to do but I want to live the
life I want and to me that means living
where you want so I I would I would
personally never ever move somewhere
just to save on taxes well you've done
the exact opposite you you you live
currently in you live in the highest tax
place in America I believe correct and
um I'm totally fine with that because
again like money enables me to live the
life I want
I just tend to think and it's ironic
because you know I'm running a company
that helps people save money on taxes
the kinds of people who spend all their
life worrying about taxes are some of
the unhappiest people I know so I don't
ever want to get to that point and
sometimes when you move to like you know
a Utopia with zero taxes you're
surrounded with everyone else that moved
there for that reason that's your group
your friends are other people who hate
taxes and I don't know if if you know
that's the Social Circle I want dude we
had John Lee Dumis on the Pod do you
remember this Sean and we were talking
about taxes and he was like bragging
about how he moved to Puerto Rico or
something like that dude he was glowing
I thought he was pregnant I was like wow
this guy's so happy he moved to Puerto
Rico and he was so happy about it and he
and then he started making fun of me
that I didn't live in Puerto Rico like
do you remember that he was like
insulting me and I was like John we're
not close enough that you can make fun
of me that
hard this a
podcast um you know I think that the
thing you know a lot of people who
listen this podcast we all share one
goal prob
uh we we have many different goals but
one we share is we all want Financial
Freedom and most people think Financial
Freedom is oh I'm free to buy what I
want do what I want it's the financial
leather jacket you're a financial badass
now all right cool but I think the real
Financial Freedom is when money doesn't
have a hold on you so it's not about
exactly you being able to buy and do
certain things it's that money no longer
dictates your decisions money does not
control you or or uh make you do things
that you don't want to do and so it's
it's more of freedom from money not
freedom to spend money you had a point
on on this thing I want you to explain
and it's really a direct attack at Sam
you said the point of having money is to
not worry about money if you are wealthy
but still stressed about money which I
see all the time you're missing the
point all right Sam look this man in the
eye and unker tell him D I don't I don't
blame I don't blame him if if it's him
or anyone else cuz these are beliefs we
form very young in life like at to some
degree they're not even fully conscious
beliefs so if they're not conscious
beliefs to try and sort of program it
but yeah I have so many like super weldy
friends friends you know with hundreds
of millions of dollars who are stressed
about the pursuit of more money they are
100 millionaires who want to be
billionaires or something and and again
like you said it really well right the
whole point of money is to be free from
it and do what you want like to me the
best thing I bought with money was being
able to say no to a job that would have
paid me tens of millions of dollars in
equity because guess what I don't need
it anymore can I just say Sean so look I
give let me defend myself I came on here
and I express uh my belief on money and
how I'm fearful of it and how I want it
to make me happy it doesn't but you did
Camp MFM you told me about Joe gbia Joe
gbia is worth1 billion doll and you told
me this crazy story and it blew my mind
about how happy is and everything like
this and so I radically changed my
opinion on money and happiness and now I
realize I just need 10 billion to be
happy that's all I need is 10 billion so
like my opinion has been changed it's no
longer about scarcity mindset if I have
10 billion I will be happy there you go
I'm glad I'm glad you've been
enlightened all right Anor um give me a
couple other quick hot takes before we
no you're gotta make fun of Sean now
which is there's no true Alpha yeah
let's frame it you said there's no true
Alpha in investing I realized that's
sort of a Fool's game that's why instead
I realized I can I can optimize my tax
setup and make more money that way than
try to beat the market as a guy who uh
has been attempting to beat the market
for quite some time now successfully
how's that been going wait answer the
question what are the wins and what are
the losses and we're not talking about
private we're talking about uh have you
been try have you did you try to beat
the market in terms of public too he
looks kind of sheepish he looks kind of
sheepish he's he's like yeah trying to
make me cry What's Happening Here uh no
no no I I I don't know I actually don't
know if you pick and choose stocks I
know you pick and choose private
companies but that was like your job I
agree that most people cannot beat the
market I do not agree that nobody can
beat the market over
I know that that's an unpopular opinion
and I know that you know the famous
Warren Buffett bet I know all those
things I just refuse to believe that
it's it's not a bell curve so um I think
the people that beat the market spend
all their lives doing that with their
own Capital right like think about Jim
Simmons right his hedge fund is returned
like 40% on average they're not taking
outside Capital what I think is a little
bit of a scam is a lot of the financial
services industry that tries to promise
you outsize returns um who promises that
like like like what what's that
stereotype hedge funds because I I've
never met like a financial adviser that
would be dumb enough to promise that any
any actively managed fund right so yes
hedge funds are a big big sort of thing
any active stock picking fund I mean
there's a lot of stock picking funds
that charge you one to two 1% a year um
and their portfolio they say will
outperform or whatever um so does every
real estate fund Venture fund basically
like anything that charges outsized fees
anything that charges more than a
Vanguard fund that's crazy that that
people like buy into that though correct
so our our thesis is all always like
okay fine I do think better tax strategy
can actually create alpha alpha is a you
know Finance term for like you will
outperform um and using that tax Alpha
to just put more dollars in the market I
think is a smarter approach and the
approach I like and you know I'm taking
with my money as well out of 100% of
your net worth is 100% of it in the S&P
index or no absolutely not like I have I
have a lot of it not in the S&P index
but that's my fund money I think there's
a good chance I don't outperform um and
a lot of it is in private uh private
investing which are funds that I own but
I think I'm the only person I know who
has a fund is biggest mine and charges
no management fees the average Venture
fund charges 20 to 25% just in
management fees and and the average
person does not realize that we charge
zero percent Sean do you know how I tell
tell you that I don't buy individual
stocks yeah I real I looked at my
portfolio the other day it was the first
time in a year that I looked at it and I
realized I was wrong I've done it twice
or three times
the company that I did it on was play
was Playboy uh I had read I read their
annual report yeah you can't just call
their magazine their annual report dude
that's called their monthly
calendar yeah but yeah actually their
annual report they have a lot of photos
uh
and oh Jenny old Jenny McCarthy picture
holding up the ballad sheet that's nice
uh I uh I did that because I was like oh
look like they're prop they're their
their real estate asset is worth more
than what they're trying to sell the
company for and I was like that's smart
I'll do that did not win on that one so
lost on that one also did coinbase at
the IPO God and then I sold it uh two
weeks before it popped like three months
ago or whatever whenever it was so I've
I've done I've done two you've also done
it with HubSpot you got HubSpot stock
you could have sold it Diversified you
decided to hold that is a decision to
buy that's correct I and and with BMB
yeah correct the two biggest Holdings in
your portfolio correct so you do it too
we all do no those aren't my those
aren't my two biggest Holdings the my
index funds are significantly larger but
uh yeah I have done so I've done it as
well so I'm like you Anor I have my fund
money thing it's just that I happen to
have a fun money stash that's 80%
instead of 20% yeah I mean look at the
end of the day as long as we realize
what we're doing it's fine right like I
I think we all have to learned this
lesson ourselves in 2021 I thought I was
a damn genius I was like these index
funds are stupid my portfolio is up like
300% I should just be a stock picker for
life and yeah then you come back to
reality and realize what was there was
was there a day where you're like H huh
that's not the way it was many because
again if you remember there's such an
insane runup for a while you couldn't
lose every company was up 100% day on
day it was when investing was the most
fun it should not be that fun and then
yeah there were numerous days of like
cool I've lost $300,000 today cool down
half a million dollars today cool and
just that happen happening repeatedly
while the S&P 500 kind of just kept
chipping away and growing and you know
Nvidia comes out of nowhere and all
these stocks that I only held because I
had an index fund otherwise I had no
exposure Sean let me an Anor let me tell
you this crazy story about uh tax stuff
that I learned this is like one of those
tax hacks I'm not the biggest fan of tax
hacks but this is actually a good one I
met this lady she was speaking at one of
our events and uh I don't want to say
her name of her company but she was on
the commercial for this credit card
company because she loved the credit
card so much and her business was doing
let's say 50 million a year and she was
putting a lot of of it on a credit card
and it was giving her $300,000 a year of
either points or cash back and according
to the IRS a cash cash back from a
credit card is considered a rebate
correct and I believe you get up to I
don't remember what it is I don't know
what it is now but three years ago when
she told me this she said it's uh
$300,000 a year of of rebates is that
you know what it is nowadays is it same
something like that depends on the card
itself but yeah oh I I thought it was by
the government I thought it was limited
to the government must have been limited
to the credit card she was getting
$300,000 a year of cash back of which
she was like that's my salary I don't
take a salary or I take a very
unmeaningful salary for my company and
I'm living off my credit card points and
that was pretty wild did you know you
could actually pay your taxes at a
credit card and it's for some people you
could actually like Arbitrage that where
again this is insane I would never do it
but it's just I just found it
interesting you can pay your taxes on a
credit card there's not a very high
extra fee and in a lot of cases you can
actually end up slightly better it's a
very painful thing to do David David
Hower did it David Hower sold his
company grasshopper I think for $200
million and he paid his taxes on his AMX
and he called AMX and he told him what
he was going to do and so I don't I
don't remember what the bill is but
let's say 20 or $30 million of a tax
bill he paid that on his AMX and he goes
I've got I just got you know a couple
decades with the flights insane that's
that's the other thing with credit card
points is once you learn how to use them
for travel the cash back feels less good
like yes the cash back has a theoretical
value but there's so much more valuable
applied to travel once you kind of learn
how the game works what's the smart way
to do it okay so the thing you always
want to avoid is never spend the points
on your credit card website that is the
thing almost everyone does and you lose
a ton of value there I do that yeah so
what you want to do instead is create an
account with an airline like I do it
with Emirates a lot because I fly
internet or with Air France km the
International Airlines are the best look
up a flight on their loyalty program do
the transfer it takes like 30 seconds
and you'll probably save 70% points
right there no way 70% yeah I've I've
tested this a lot because what these it
says transfer like there's a tiny link
that says Transfer Partners and you have
to that's where you send your points you
never spend it in the thing that's going
to save you so Point I've spent I've
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
on flights over the past 10 years
through Chase my Chase card I found this
out two years ago it was life changing
yeah absolutely what you got you got
hosed bro that it's so bad to do it wait
you knew that Sean yeah I PID for this
guy Mo points he's like this guy who'll
call you he'll teach you about credit
card points uh or like he he'll just be
like what's your situation here's what
your credit card setup should be and
here's how to use it and so he showed it
to me and I was like wow that was like
the best $300 I've ever spent because
that one session which I thought H 300
bucks to do this call that's that's kind
of a lot of course I mean the Savings in
just understanding how to book the
flights better because he's like this is
luxury travel you want to travel first
class all around the world here's what
you need to do and for for me I have an
Ecom business so we're spending millions
of a year in ads so he's like you need
this MX gold because it gives you 4X on
every Facebook point that you uh every
dollar you spend on Facebook or Google
and so you're getting 4X multipliers
he's like but then you got to transfer
it out and then you got to use this
website website like points at me or
whatever to um be able to search for
points across all the airlines yeah I
think just transferring out is the 820
if you want to tell someone in one
sentence how to do better transfer your
points out do you have any more of those
little little tricks what else you got
in your hat come on magician pull
something that's Prett aesome solo 41k
so that's the one that you have on here
that I don't know anything about what is
a solo 41k so solo 401K this is the
first product we built and I had an LLC
for a while I was earning some you know
some random money and I saw I found this
account called a solo 401K which is like
your own like your corporate 401K but it
exists exclusively for you and with that
you can do really cool things so one you
can put in up to $69,000 a year
typically if you max out your corporate
account it's very hard to hit the max
because your company match is not enough
but with a solo 401K you can put in
$69,000 a year get that as a tax
deduction um the second thing is you
could do the whole thing as a Roth
contribution so if you read about Peter
theel and how he grew his you know
billion dollar Roth IRA traditionally
with the Roth IRA you can only put in
$7,000 can you tell the Peter teal story
real quick how did he use a Roth IRA to
make billions oh man this was both
genius and kind of possibly illegal but
what he did is he bought his founder
shares at PayPal with his Roth IRA so he
spent like $2,000 to buy PayPal shares
that became worth $27 million when
PayPal sold and then he had $27 million
to just make all kinds of Investments he
allegedly bought his like Facebook
shares 10% of Facebook from his Roth IRA
so he's gonna turn 59 and a half in a
year and he's gonna have five billion do
taxfree which is pretty wild the wildest
part about that what you just said is
that Peter teal only made $27 million
selling PayPal yeah yeah I realize me
and Peter teal are sort of uh we're sort
of you know apples and apples I
guess right Sam like the the hustle and
PayPal netted the founders very similar
amounts of money that's kind of amazing
well what what we don't know is if Peter
theel H had others shairs not in his
rotha which is quite possible actually
ah damn news too G to be true let's just
take
it probably not he's gonna have to show
that to me for me to change my opinion
yeah yeah I'm not gonna let facts get in
the way of me beating Peter te what
about uh can a person have more than one
401K yeah so that's what's cool is if
you have a full-time job and a side
hustle you can have a solo 401K for your
business while still contributing to
your employer 401K um but because it's
your own 401K you can invest it in
anything right your employer 401K has
like a list of very specific assets with
a solo 401K you can invest it however
you want if you need liquidity you could
borrow up to $50,000 from it it's simply
the most powerful retirement account in
America but it's not available unless
you have your own business isn't the
normal 401K kind of a racket like the
thing where they're like you can only
buy these These funds using our 401K is
that because they get a lot of them have
fees no it comes from the 401K provider
the long answer is uh corporate 401K
plant are subject to irell laws like
employment retirement investment
something act and those those acts are
just there to protect employees but as a
result employers can't do things that
help them like there limits on how much
you can contribute to yourself if your
employees are part of the same plan
limit to Investments but if there's no
employees go crazy so the solo 41k you
could put that in could you like put in
real estate could you put in anything is
it like absolutely if yeah the only
thing you can't do which is where the
whole Peter thei thing may be slightly
illegal is you can't have a self-dealing
transaction so I can't invest in my
startup I can invest in Sam's startup
that's totally fine but I can't invest
in my own company I can't invest in my
house but I can do commercial real
estate gotcha okay that's self-dealing
for him is it if you that's just a a
major Angel investment he was the
founder too which is why it's sketch he
was the founder of PayPal remember if he
was just an angel investor it's
fine to much he you know we might might
be an accident for encor if you keep
talking like this out loud he's got5
billion dollar writing on nobody paying
too much attention to this yeah I mean
look so people because know people ask
us all the time can I do what Peter
theel did and I was like look it may be
fine if you don't own over 50% I
wouldn't because again like the thing
with the IRS is a lot of these things
are not clear rules there rules written
a certain way somewhat interprets them
somehow the IRS challenges it sometimes
the IRS loses in court and that's how
loopholes are established right so so
like the problem that I have with my my
personal bookkeepers or accountants my
CPA like they're pretty reactionary so
it's like at the end of the year like we
are dealing the problems and then
everyone makes the same thing where they
say next year I'm doing this right but
I'll worry about it in like two or three
months and then two or three months
becomes like way later that's the real
New Year's resolution to be honest is
the 3 week after tax after file your
taxes is the the real New Year's
resolution to be honest candidly that's
the problem we're having cuz right now
we're realizing we have to educate the
CPAs a lot and almost everyone that
comes to us this a bu a sample they do
not like their CPA um and we don't do
that yet right like maybe there's a
world will do it but who do you have
like do you hire like a tax strategist
who is like more offensive and do they
they work in tandem with your CPA what
do you do so for me personally once I've
you know gone down this Rabbit Hole um
we're doing this internally we have a
program where we help people with the
tax strategy part we don't do tax
filings I'm basically using our our own
services but yeah there's a big part
that's tax strategy that is not the
person signing off your tax return
should they be separate the way the
world is written today the like just
laws and stuff it is because the person
filing your taxes typically doesn't do
that much strategy um it's sort of just
why like even if let's say you want to
set up a trust you need an estate
attorney who's different from your
financial adviser who's different from
your accountant and to the average
person you're like why why can't one
person do this and those are the kinds
of things we're thinking a lot about
like how do we productize this in some
way shape or form while still being
compliant because compliance is a big
big big part anytime you try and build
these kinds of businesses so I was so uh
you know stressed out last tax season uh
you know that I was like okay how am I
going to do things differently this year
so I I was like I'm going to treat this
like it's it's it's my own business it's
its own product it's its own company I'm
starting and so I was like I'm going to
go on a road show and I'm going to go
and basically see who's out there you
know go give me your best pitch and I
created a data room I was like this is
my tax setup and I put all the time in
like here's a flowchart here's my prior
years returns here's what here's what I
paid in taxes here's what my expectation
is for next year I was like here's a
turnkey data room so I don't even have
to have a phone call with you I'm like I
have the phone call and I on the phone
call I tell them exactly what I want
because for some reason I would like go
to these tax people and I think it's an
insecurity It's like because I don't
know as much about taxes as you I kind
of defer everything and I almost become
like I work for you and then I'm like
like splash water on my face I'm like wa
no no I'm paying you hold on wait this
is backwards you work for me I forgot
why am I pretending like I I I have to
tiptoe around even asking you for what I
want and so I go in and I'm like I felt
this way I never want to feel this way
again I want somebody who's going to
take care of everything I you know
everything from I want you to literally
I want you to be able to pay bills if I
need you to up to filing my my returns
for all of these you know I got 12
entities all 12 entities um and I need
you to do strategy and I need you to be
coming to me every you know every
quarter with proactive suggestions about
what I should be doing um that's what I
want who can provide me that and I went
on tour basically and it's such a better
way than I was doing before I highly
recommend this for anybody who's like
has enough income and kind of uh
business value where that makes sense to
do which I don't know what that number
is probably different for a lot of
people it wouldn't have made sense sense
for me three years ago to do that it's
like ah whatever you're paying you know
a couple hundred K in taxes or you know
even a million dollars in taxes probably
not worth that much effort to go do but
as you scale I think it's important to
do that I'm realizing now yep and I also
think it has to be a collaboration it's
very hard a lot of people are like oh if
I had a tax guide they would solve all
my issues but a lot of the best
strategies they're like longterm right
let's say you want to start a business
to get acquired 5 years later that's the
kind of stuff that you like need a
partnership to be discussing and have
someone you're working with somewhat at
least quarterly right because there's a
lot of this stuff that like this the
more you know the more you'll push them
and the better the things you'll achieve
I'm actually going to do that data room
thing that's the second thing that
you've said in the last few months that
it's like going to have a change in my
life that's really smart the first thing
bro we talk twice a week on this podcast
that's the second thing in months that
was good yeah yeah well the well like a
lot of the stuff you say I'm like I'm
either already doing that or I don't
want to do that or uh like I'm not sure
if you're right or that's only okay but
the you said that data room thing is
actually a really Wise Wise way to look
at it the other thing that you said it
was and it hit me I was like that's
brilliant and it was uh when you were
selling one your uh your house in San
Francisco you so like I forget what real
estate agents make 6% but you're like
but 6% is not that that the difference
between 2 million and 2.2 million is
like 6% isn't that meaningful for the
realer but it's really meaningful for me
as the owner that's a six figure
difference so I'll just give you my real
estate agent I'll tell you hey if you
get anything above my asking price of
like 2.1 which is my happy number but if
you get anything above that like 2.2
I'll actually give you like 30% of the
fee so I'm selling a piece of property
now and that's what I told my I went I
just right after the the Pod I went and
called her right away I go hey how about
this yeah I didn't do 30% that's crazy
but I did more I I did more than the 6%
so you uh you messed that one up a
little bit but it's okay well but but
but the thing is is like even I I don't
remember what dollar right each
additional dollar past that is like yeah
you said like 10% I think you even said
like You' buy this person a burka bag
you said something like crazy I had a
negative incentive too no no I said and
if you don't get me the price that you
comped me when you when you won this
listing okay there has to be some
incentive or disincentive if you don't
live up to your word what real estate
agents do is on the way in they're like
they woo you oh we're gonna this will be
great I've done such similar sales I
think we can get you what what price do
you think oh yeah I think we can get you
that price and then afterwards two weeks
later they're like oh just the market is
so you know right now you know the thing
is blah blah blah and then then then
they're just negging you and they're
trying to reduce your expectations so
that when an offer comes in you'll take
it whatever it is because they just want
to turn the deal over yeah right because
they're they're getting 3% on two
billion bucks they don't really care if
it's two point if it's 2 million 50,000
or two million they'd rather just get
the deal done and so
I knew that they do that neing so up
front when I said when he's promising me
the world I said all right cool but if
you don't do it you got to buy my wife
this bag and um he was like laughing and
I was like I let it sit there for a
second and he's like oh you're for real
and I was like yeah he's like okay deal
and then literally when we were coming
when we're coming to do the deal he's
like I really don't want to buy your
wife that bag let me go back to them and
see if I can get more and he got an
extra like $30,000 a after that uh you
know that last comment so I appreciate
it the reason why it broke my frame was
because these are like a realtor is like
uh you you think like well for some
reason you think this is just the law or
like there is no negotiating like this
is how it's always been done and I must
do it this way I'm just and and when I
was thinking about it I was like no that
the way that he actually said is 100%
better I didn't realize that I could
like question them right you know what I
mean and there's actually like what's
crazy is there's people who do that with
the IRS as well so for example Sean
Parker I believe is the guy who created
either created or he was uh important
with helping create it with
opportunity zones in real estate yep and
like I remember like reading about
opportunity zones and I be like oh Shawn
Parker created I'm like wait what and I
guess like the story is is he was young
he was still in his 20s and he convinced
the government that it's wise to invest
into opportunity zones which is uh real
estate that's in areas that are
impoverished or or we want them to be
better and I'm like how ballsy of that
kid to go and convince the IRS or the
government that this is the right move
and I and I love like stories like that
and uh that that was it was a wild story
let's do a couple more before we before
we finish so you said owning real estate
with your business what's this one yeah
so another great example right so Sam
said okay what if I have a million
dollars in business profits like what
can I do to lower my tax bill just
buying your office building or if you
have a physical building connected to
anything you're doing whether it's your
office whether you have a retail
location if you own that real estate you
can use depreciation um to offset 20 30%
of the purchase price as a business law
that year so which is why you'll see a
lot of old school businesses they
actually own their properties they're
not just renting since you just save so
much money um people take this you can
also do this with cars and you know buy
a vehicle attached to your business you
have the whole like insanity where you
can actually depreciate more of the
purchase price if your car weighs over
6,000 pounds which is insane and why you
have the whole like G-Wagon tax right
off meme um but yeah owning real estate
of your businesses is massive that's
like the classic like immigrant story
which is like a mom and pop like came
here from Vietnam and then they bought
they just they eventually bought their
Corner Store building and then they the
building becomes worth significantly
more than the corner store and then they
bought their G
wagon and the G
wagon like again T like business owners
were already very favored as Were Real
Estate developers but when Trump was in
office he actually took it the next
level with the tax cuts and jobs act
that basically doubled those benefits it
gave an extra benefit to business
business owners where they get to deduct
20% of their income called qualified
business income deduction and it allowed
real estate developers um and and your
boy Nick Hubert talks about all the time
to do what's called bonus depreciation
and depreciate 20 to 30% of the purchase
price upfront um so even though the code
is already written this way there's
always new incentives to further make it
even better for business owners and real
estate developers let's do some of these
uh other things you you you had a good
thing on happiness I want to read it to
you basically you were like happiness
it's not that complicated uh what is the
kind of what are the four things that
that actually matter when it comes to
happiness yeah I mean look after I sold
my company I spent two years traveling
chilling you know I was like wow you
know we spent all our lives waiting to
like retire what if I just lived a
retired life now um and a lot of f was
like okay fine what are my happiness
triggers and I found for me was very
very simple um the two two like critical
things for like my environment were
plenty of time Outdoors ideally with
sunlight like constant movement like Sam
didn't believe me when I told him I walk
20,000 steps a day at to produce
receipts um doing work that's an insane
amount that is an insane amount three
and a half years it's just it's just
what keeps me keeps me going dude my my
trailing 90 days because we had the baby
was uh 3,100 steps a day yeah that to me
that's misery like I I just need to I
need to be in motion what do what do you
do to get those 20,000 steps like do you
have did you like replace meetings with
walking meetings or something like what
what did you do in your meetings phone
calls like um a big part of my rtin
playing sports every day though again
like it's winter here and that's why I
hate winter cuz like now I'm not getting
my outdoor time and my walking has come
down a lot um but yeah so happiness
triggers movement uh being able to spend
time Outdoors having a higher purpose
for me that's work with meaning but for
other people you know it's religion it's
just something that is like bigger than
themselves and four is like
relationships that count I can like
simplify my life to these four
components and like repr like that's all
it takes for at least me to just be very
very happy are you dating anyone uh no
right now you probably crush it though
in that department right yeah look I
mean again I I enjoy I enjoy being
single uh but at the same time look I'm
34 years old and the parental pressure
is ramping up we'll see how it goes
you're like I can defeat the IRS but not
not the parental pressure yeah how old
were you Sam when you when you and Sarah
got together she was
22 and I was 25 oh damn you were young
it didn't feel that way cuz I went
pretty crazy between like 19 and 24 like
I I I I did some fun things yeah
actually I've actually drank a beer with
you there's not a lot of people at this
chapter of your life that have done that
but yeah yeah that's true that's true
and I had a lot of fun I did this
CrossCountry motorcycle trip and after I
just sold the company and I didn't sell
it for a lot of money I had like $50,000
in my bank account but I was like 23
riding my motorcycle cross country
telling people I just sold my company on
Tinder was this apartment list or
whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah it was two
apartment L
and I and I just hosted a conference so
I had money and like it was I was the
coolest guy ever for like eight weeks
and then I met my wife like right when I
got home yeah um but uh yeah we've been
together for a while uh it's honestly
awesome I like I I don't even like
talking about this because I remember
when we got married we had to go to like
and talk to a priest because we got
married in Catholic church and I was
like telling her I was like telling the
priest I was like yeah we uh you know
we're a good partnership we talk about
like business and stuff all the time
he's like well what about love so like I
don't even like mentioning this but like
basically dating someone who is smart
and you eventually want to marry it's
actually makes you more money that's not
the most important thing but I think
like what I've learned is having a good
relationship I think actually was the
greatest financial decision I made I
mean you're not you're probably less
distracted right like people in people
in relationships are like eventually
like on are kind of more stable I think
I remember when I was when I was selling
my business I was negotiating with the
the dude who like runs General Atlantic
big big private Equity Fund and he's
like an old school guy he's like are you
married I was like no kids no he like I
don't like that I can't trust single
people you have nothing to lose I I
don't like it I would feel much better
about this deal if you were married and
had a family because you're scared you'd
be more nervous more scared of stuff
you're like for for $250 million I can
get a 30-day fiance right now sir what
what do you need yeah yeah so Sean when
your wife goes out of town are you like
me where you're like uh what the hell am
I supposed to do like what do what do I
do it's three hours of heaven but
anything beyond three hours I'm like H
this boring like this is this sucks like
it's so quiet in here like I started
walking around circles like my dog or
something I don't know what to do I want
to talk about one more thing we have a
large Indian listenership you're welcome
yeah thank you Sean uh I feel like
everyone in my life is is like all my
best friends are Indian you're like
going on a tear on social media saying
uh like particularly you're like you
know East Asian people we've got the
stereotype of of us not having a lot of
muscle in reality it's just because we
eat like or what did you say the
Indian diet is just by default not great
for building strength for staying in
shape and things are really bad right
now like an Indian person living in
North America right so we have the same
exact like upbringing whatever is
anywhere between four to six times more
likely to have heart disease diabetes
like it's just it's real bad and now
that I guess I have more of a voice on
social media and people are listening I
feel like it's something worth talking
about since I don't know like if if I
could have some impact over the next 10
20 30 years to change that that would go
a long way but the hardest part is
there's this like cultural like you know
deniability where Indian people get
really mad when you tell them that um if
every even even now I mean you know if
you try tweeting out the Indian diet is
like traditionally unhealthy or
something you'll get all these people in
India like getting super super angry
about it but ask anyone who's ever I
don't know do you ever count Macos Sam
or Sean yeah I I I use my fitness pal
every day for like the past four years
Okay cool so there's not one person
who's ever counted macros who will fight
the indan diet as healthy like not one
it's impossible it is actually
impossible if you track it to to see it
um yet it produces this passionate
response I mean I ended up commenting on
an Indian cricketer's physique and an
Indian newspaper the Hindustan times ran
this like article about me saying Indian
ameran entrepreneur fat shames like
cricketer and I had to like turn off my
Instagram because I got hundreds
thousands of comments like just
attacking me my family and everything I
stood for because I'm not being like you
know a proud Indian or whatever so
that's hilarious man the uh the I went
to an Indian grocer Sam you probably
don't know this there's actually just
like Indian grocery shops SE we have our
own separate
secret okay so most don't really realize
this but if you walk
in every single aisle literally is the
shittiest food that you could possibly
eat and I went in there and I was like
you know Jim Carrey in The Truman Show
when he's like wait this sky is actually
like a wall like what what is this what
what's happening in here and I was
literally like running down the a like
what's happening in here this is fried
it's all fried why is everything fried
literally not one thing and and no
protein right it's like fried and zero
protein it's literally fried
carbohydrates with some fat and like
that's everything and you just see the
moms just putting things in there for
their kids I'm like don't don't do this
man this is so bad it's literally
so bad and to the point where I was like
should someone create like a just a
better for you Indian food that goes
into the Indian grocery so you're the
only skew in the store that is not like
deep fried terrible everything or like
you know just canned gabim on or
something it's like this terrible
terrible food um and that's not even
like the home food that's like the
grocery store right so if you're in it's
like garbage in garbage out it's like if
your inputs are all terrible then the
are also going to be terrible um why
they just don't care is it not part of
the it's just not part of the culture
protein is just not really deeply
embedded in in Indian food and it is it
is small parts but it's just not really
a big deal and it's compounded when you
live in America but I think about it
this way right I joked about this but
like I think the spelling be is the only
time I see Indian people on ESPN
obviously an
exaggeration ultimate burn dude that's
so good yeah I mean look as an IDI
person I can say it I don't think you
can say it Sam You' get canceled uh but
yeah like it's it's it's really not good
what I think is optimistically my
generation we're seeing people being
aware of this we're we're seeing this
changing a lot of South Asian people
right they're always like even like baji
was on a podcast he's like oh yeah I did
like as well as I could for my South
Asian genetics I actually think that's
kind of I think South Asian
genetics are honestly not bad at all for
people who work out and and kind of eat
clean and whatever I mean all the Indian
friends I have that have put in the
effort have seen results but the whole
stereotype I think starts because of the
diet yeah I've been on an Indian food
kick lately and it's been all like
coconut milk and so I've just not been
using that or coconut it's just all
creamy and and and it tastes so
good going in but it does not feel
wonderful and Indian parents when they
feed you and because I'll be like Mom
why did you give us this and she's like
this is good for you I'm like how is
this good for you and she' be like gives
you energy and I think they literally
took the idea of calories as like you
know calories like a measure of energy
it's like yeah they were like gives you
energy this carbohydrate you're going to
have so much energy and I'm like not
that's not how it works and even they're
like oh doll doll has tons of protein
it's like lentils basically it's like
yeah but has like you know the macros on
dollar like 20 grams of protein 35 grams
of of carbs and then you add butter ghee
and like oil to the thing to make it
taste good it's like well that's not
really going to help then right like
that and doll is your protein in the
rest of your meal right you have all
this other stuff like oh for protein
I'll have doll that's a great example
and yeah like Indian people will like
the Indian Express actually ran an
article being like yep we thought dll
had a lot of protein too like the
awareness is increasing now but it's
it's pretty slow I went to a uh what's
it called is it a holly or holy a holy
celebration and it was uh naan with ghee
is a ghee so like that clear clear
butter and then uh tons of uh butter
buttered chicken but instead of chicken
it was cheese oh God
and and then it was like the dessert was
fried dough and maple syrup what do you
guys call GL jump it's delicious by the
way it's delicious like don't yeah yeah
yeah it's good for you because it made
me smile and smiling is good for you but
uh it didn't feel great uh two hours
later yeah and here's what's changing
though is now Indian people are really
weldy there's four million Indian people
they have an average income of $100,000
the wealthiest ethnic group so I do
think things will change like it used to
not be a very viable Market but now
there's a lot of fuzz and it's a very
big market so I think all of these
businesses also make good commercial
sense if you read in our comment section
on YouTube um the most recurring comment
is Sean you look great Sean are you
losing weight Sean that beard looks
wonderful so Sean's gonna be a sex $10
on Fiverr you can get that anybody can
get that for you go pay five go pay a
Fiverr you can get people saying how
good you look on YouTube I guess
everyone's commenting on Sean's looks
except for like they'll either they'll
make fun of his outfit cuz he wears like
a Mickey Mouse t-shirt or they'll be
like Sean your workout program it's
working so well like people are just
sucking up to him so much well yep thank
you and uh Anker where should people
find you where how do they go and use
your product that helps them with taxes
yeah absolutely we're called carry we're
at kry money.com and if anyone wants to
set up a solo 401k or just get better at
what they pay in taxes check us out
appreciate you thank you thanks for
coming man sweet man this is
fun
[Music]
a